what it looks like in biology is that
the rules or the laws depend on the
state this is typical computer science
this is obvious to you you know the
update rule depends on the state of the
machine right but and you know you don't
think about um uh you know that being
sort of the dynamic in
physics it's you know the rules given to
you and then it you know it's a it's a
very special subclass say of
computations if
you know you don't ever change the
update
um but in biology it seems to be that
the state and the law change together as
a function of time and we don't have
that as a paradigm in physics um and so
a lot of people talked about this as
being kind of a perplexing feature
that maybe there are certain scenarios
where the laws of physics or the laws
that govern a particular system actually
change the function of the state of that
system that's trippy
the hope of physics
it's a hope i guess
but often stated as a
underlying assumption is that the law
is uh static right
okay and even having laws that vary in
time and not even as a function of state
is very radical
when you the time in general like yeah
you want to remove time from the
equation as much as possible yeah i i do
um there's some interesting things in
this like when we think sort of deep
more deeply about the actual physics
that we're trying to propose governs
life um with me with collaborators and
then also other people that think about
similar things that time might actually
be fundamental and there really is an
ordering to time um and that events in
the universe are unique because they
have a particular you know they they
happen like an object in the universe
requires a certain history of events in
order to exist which therefore suggests
that time really does have an ordering
i'm not talking about the flow of time
and our perception of time just the
ordering of events causation of things
yes causation there's that word again so
causation that's when you say time you
mean causation yes
in your proposed
model
of the physics of life the the
fundamental thing would be causation if
you were to bet your money on one
particular horse or whatever yes and
then space is emergent
yes so everything's emergent except time
kind of yeah or causation
change all the time why does it look
like laws are the same laws well because
uh well one way um and i actually this
idea comes from lee cronin because i
work with him very closely on these
things is that the laws of physics look
the way they do because they're low
memory laws so they don't require a lot
of information to specify them they're
very easy for the universe to implement
but if you get something like me
for example i require 4 billion year
history to exist in the universe i come
with a lot of historical baggage
and that's part of what i am as a set of
causes that exist in the universe
so i have local rules that apply to me
that are associated with sort of the
information in my history that aren't
universal to every object in the
universe
and there are some things that are very
easily easy to implement low memory
rules that apply to everything in the
universe
so there's no shortcuts to you no i so
yeah i don't believe in like things like
boltzmann brains or
uh you know fluctuations out of the
vacuum that can produce things like your
desk ornaments um
i actually think they require a
particular causal chain of events to
exist
you